abone ol
bu fotoğraf yaka derdiler İbni Haldun
Eğer benim gibi mümit olmayan bir
coğrafyada dolmuş sanız Biz tekrar
ayakta kalmak ve kendi doğumunuzu
sağlamak için kahramanlara ihtiyacımız
vardır benim iki kahramanım vardı Biri
babam
ve kendisini hep çokça kitap okurken
görürdüm Çocukluğumda özellikle elektrik
elektronik ve bilim teknik okurdu
kendisine sorduğumuz zaman derdi ki ben
yedi yılda anca İlkokulu bitirdim fakat
biz seni 970 hiçbir köyde elektriğin
olmadığı zamanlarda bizim evde elektrik
vardı çünkü hemen toprağımız dan çıkan
su da küçük mini bir Hidroelektrik
Santrali kurarak elektrik üretmeye
başlamıştı kapama düğmesi yok faturada
gelmiyor ha tamamen faturasız bütün
mahalleye verdi elektrik ikinci Cadı da
Bebekken çok ağlamışım şıma Ağlama
sesiyle sallanan beşik icat etti yarım
mucidi sayılırım
Bu nasıl küskündür değilsem
karışıklığında arkasından Evin
bahçesinde bir sürü böyle motor
parçaları kablolar en az iki tane
arabanın yapıldığını gördüm fırsatı
olsaydı 1970'lerde Muhtemelen yerli ilk
otomobilinize biniyor olurduk Evet yedi
yılda İlkokulu bitirmişti çok soru
sorardı sürekli soru sorardı ve soru
sorduğumuzda da kesinlikle cevap
vermezdim önce bizim fikrimiz alırdı
o kendi coğrafyasının içerisinde çok
değerli bir hazine neydi ama coğrafyanın
sınırları içerisinde kaldığı ve gitti
Onun için çocukluğumuzda bize ve bana
hatırladığım tek hediyesi yerkürede
yerküre hediye etmişti Barbie bebekler
vesaire yok o zamanlarda O yerküre ile
bize bütün kıtaları ve dünyaya gelme
amacımızı anlatmıştım şu
bu iki kahramanın 11 yaşında Devlet
Parasız Yatılı okuluna gittim Yatılı
okulda okuyan larımız var mı
Bu benim jenerasyon alıp tüm Evet Okulun
ilk günü
de salya sümük alıyoruz Çünkü
ailelerimizin terk ettiğini düşünüyoruz
bizi Aslında amaçları kaliteli bir
eğitim almak için en uygun okul ortamı O
dönemlerde Devlet Parasız Yatılı Okulun
ilk günü öğretmenimiz geldi bi gerçek
bir öğretmen bize dedi ki çocuklar niçin
ağlıyorsunuz Siz seçilmişsin izogün
gerçekten kelimelerin sihirli bir etkisi
olduğunu anladım Çünkü Bizi yerden
kaldırmış birden şövalyelik ünvanı
vermişti bir seçilmişti kaba öğlen
yemeklerinde çıkan yemeklerimizin
içerisinde böcekleri ayırıp biliyorduk
yazık hocam nasıl seçilmiş izbiz diyordu
ki bütün seçilmişler Zorluklara karşı
gelmek ve onların üstesinden gelmek için
yetişmek zorundalar Yatılı okulda sadece
Akademik eğitim olmazsınız aynı zamanda
günlük hayatın akışında da çalışırsınız
mesela Yemekhaneye gidersiniz masaları
bu yatakhaneleri nöbetçi olursunuz
Kendinizden Önce küçük çocukların
bakımını üstlenir siniz çok fazla soğan
patates sormuştunuz da vardır yani 11
yaşındaki çocukların hayatı hazırlanma
biçimi bu şekildeydi
yok yani öyle bir öğretmen düşünün ki
sizi tamamen dönüştürüyor Bir sözüyle
hareketiyle davranışıyla Baştan ayağa
örnek bu o olmasaydı Muhtemelen şuan bu
kırmızı noktada olmazdım
mi Evet şimdi Geçmişe baktığımızda
Allah bizi yetiştiren Ebeveynler o iki
terlikleri doğal haliyle doğal evlerinin
beğeniyle yetiştirmişler bizi yani
onları ne dediğini oluşturan şey şu an
diyenar raflarını süsleyen ebeveyni
kitapları değil kendi yaşam
mücadelelerini verirken bir taraftan
bize ilham olmuşlar ben şimdiki
kuşakların Yani bizim Çocuklarımıza
nasıl ilham olduğunu anlamak için
çocuklarımıza sorular sordum
abone ol
da aktif olmuyor mu acaba farklı yaş
gruplarından 120 öğrenciden ailelerin
resimli çizmeleri istedik Anaokulundan
ilkokul son sınıfa kadar i
320 öğrencinin 120 4'ü babasını ekran
başında çizdi
Bu sadece iki anne kitap okuyordum
Bu benim bakalım anneler neler yapıyoruz
O bizim izliyordu
abone ol
bu anaokulundaki çocuklarımızdan
birisini resmi Serpil'in çekiyor
kardeşleriyle oynuyor Şoray anne ve baba
selfiesini çekiyor Bu
ne bu başka bir örnek çocuk kitabını
okuyor kardeşi oyuncağı ile oynuyor Baba
bilgisayarın başında Evet kitap okuyan
annelerden birisiydi ev hanımı
abone ol
bak şu Çok ilgimi çekmişti
da al işte diğer filmi çakması demiş
Babaannede Instagram'da ya da dolap da
artık aynı uygulamayı sa şu kıyafet
güzelmiş diye cep telefonuna bakıyor şu
kendisini de gidiyo çekerken çekmiş
biter bitmez kitap okuyacağım diyor
o çiçek toka der kendinden geçmiş gibi
zaman soracağım bir soru sorulur
Evet bu da dikkatimi çeken başka bir
resimdi baba ve oğul Instagram'da
anneanne TRT 1 izliyor
Ama bu saniye kadar güzel anlatmış anne
de yemek hazırlıyor
İyi seyirler
Ya anne Yiğit Baba ne yapıyorsunuz
annelerde mutfakta
Ya kızım ben de televizyon izliyorum
diye bir baba
mi Evet
yok yani
ve etkileyici değil mi biraz önce
anlattığım Baba profili Bizim kendi
çocuklarımıza ilham olma şehrimiz
rakamlar çok üzücü Açıkçası ben de iki
çocuk annesi olarak birisi olarak yaşam
mücadelesi verirken bir taraftan
çocuklarımızı ilham olmaya çalışıyoruz
burada Devlet Opera ve balesi'nde bir
Şef arkadaşımız vardı kendisiyle
çocuklarda sanat ve müzikle ilgili çokça
konuşurduk bir gün dedim ki Şefim bizim
çocuklar piyanoya başlıyor dansa müziğe
başlıyor Ama sürdüremiyoruz bir şekilde
bırakıyorlar Bu nasıl değişecek dedi ki
yani almanyada bu nasıl sürüyor En
azından bana dedi ki Melek bizim
çocukların anneleri babaları da
bu piyano çalıyor ve müziğin içindeler
ör onların Hatta anneanneleri ve
dedeleri de ayrıca sizin ülkemizdeki en
büyük sorun Sebat etmemek
ya Alman şehri gönderdik yerine İtalyan
şef geldi kendisini de aynı soruyu
sordum şu
2000'li siplin a problem var demiştim
türkülerin Siz Türklerin bir disiplin a
problem aması var
bu biliyorsunuz 21 her yıl olduğu gibi
Davos'ta 2019'da dünya ekonomik forumu
yapıldı bu formu daha çok basında
yayında 16 yaşındaki Dragon'un dünya
iklim krizi ile ilgili küresel ısınma
ile ilgili yapmış olduğu tutkulu
konuşmasından sürüyorsunuz dur hav deryu
filan diyordu Evet beni o Ekonomik
Forumu'nda en çok Davos'ta konuşulan en
çok etkileyen konulardan birisi eğitim
oturumunda konuşulan konuydu Çünkü
eğitim oturumunda konuşulan konu bizim
geleceğimizi ilgilendiren konular burada
4-5 tane özellikle çocuklarımızın sahip
olması gereken özelliklerinden
bahsettiler yaratıcı düşünme problem
çözme duygusal dayanıklılık İşbirliği ve
iletişim becerileri Aynı yıl Kasım
ayında 2019 Kasım ayında TÜSİAD bir
rapor yayınladı bu raporun içeriği de
sosyal Duygu
bu şehirlerin gelişmesi üzerineydi yani
her yerde ve her Platformu neredeyse
Eğitim'in değiştirmesi geliştirilmesiyle
ilgili tartışmalar yapılıyor fikirler
sunuluyor şimdi bunun için yapılıyor şu
Çünkü mevcuttaki eğitim sistemimiz ne
yazık ki çocuklarımızın gelecekte ayakta
kalması bu uygun becerileri ve bilgileri
sağlayamıyor Ben sistem yapımcılarından
birisi değilim sistemi değiştiremem dedi
yok Yalnız buradaki herhangi bir anne ve
babanın ya da öğretmenin sistemin
değişmesini bekleyecek yüksün olduğumuzu
düşünüyorum Bir an önce eyleme
geçmeliyiz Peki bu Eylem nereden
başlıyor Biraz önceki çizimlerde ki
portrelerin resimlerin ailelerin
değişmesiyle başlıyor Yani bizden
en çok sevdiğim bir kris varrak prescot
diyor ki çocuklar doğar doğmaz
olağanüstü bir yetenekle bir
yaratıcılıkla doğuyorlar Biz diyor bir
ne yazık ki çocukların eline Barbie'leri
ve plastik oyuncakları vererek onların
yaratıcılıklarını ellerinden aldık
Ama şu an bizim içimizde bulunduğumuz
toplum bu bu yani bize beyin olarak
hemen alışveriş merkezlerine gidip giden
önce çocuklara bir şeyler alıp kendimizi
ve çocuğu tatmin etmeye onun gelişimini
sağladığımız düşünme eğiliminde yiz
Allah bir an önce eyleme geçmemiz
gerektiğini düşünüyorum Aynı zamanda
rahmetli amcanın çok güzel bir sözü var
diyor ki
Selam bugün Eğer çocuğunuzun bugün
kendinizi yaşadığı koşullara göre
yetiştirirseniz Cinayet işlemiş
olursunuz bu kadar net yani bu çocuklar
bugün doğan bir çocuk 2040 yılında 20
yaşında olacak Hiçbirimiz şu an 2040
yılının durumunun neredeyse tahmin bile
edemiyoruz ne halde olacağız Onun için
bu becerileri şimdiden vermek zorundayız
Ama hiçbir satırını kaçırmak istemediğim
için özellikle not alıp geldi mi mal
kongreden bir sözsüz ormandaki en uzun
beşi sadece en sert palamuttan yetiştiği
için en uzun beşi olmamıştır diğer
ağaçlar onun aldığı Güneş ışığını
kesmediği çevresindeki Toprak derin ve
zengin olduğu fidanken hiçbir tavşan onu
kemirme dediği ve hiçbir Oduncu onun
Vakti gelmeden kesmediği içinde en uzun
etmesi olmuştur der biz çocuklarımızı
güçlü ve sağlam birer meşe gibi
yetiştirmeliyiz ne yazık ki günümüzdeki
okulların bunu vermek gibi bir çabası
yok görünüyor çocuklara sadece plastik
oyuncaklar vermedik önlerine Bir de
testler sunduk bu testler başkaları
tarafından sorulmuş sorular ve
sınırlandırılmış şıklardan ibarettir bir
şimdi çocukluğuma dönüp baktığımda babam
ve en kıymet verdiğim Anılarım
bu onun plan ve projelerini anlatırken
duymuş olduğu heyecan ve annemle ilgili
en kıymetli anılarında sabır Metanet
doğruluk cömertlikle ilgili olanlar
inanıyorum ki
Bu bir Annenin ve babanın evladına
verebileceği en değerli Armağan onurlu
dürüst ve anlamlı yaşanmış bir hayattır
İçinizde her bir bireyin geleceğin
kahramanı olacağına inanıyorum
birilerinin kahramanı olacağına
inanıyorum sevgilerimle